[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir aux mouvements doigts
bonsoir oui bonsoir gérard bienvenus
bienvenue sur le plateau de quotidien
voici une partie de l'équipe comme en
irak au mental et vous fatigué de vivre
effrayés de mourir
est bien celui-là c'est une bonne soirée
oui oui oui oui bon on se couche tôt
celle etienne mais c'était la saint
valentin vous n'êtes pas le coup de la
migraine hier soir non maintenant on a
un nom mais
beaucoup de migraineux en france et nous
allons d'ailleurs en parler avec le
docteur valin duc puis 2014 le
législateur à légiférer et en
l'occurrence ça n'a pas été fait allez
donc ça devient compliqué la zone tendue
la loi allure bon bref nous sommes
aujourd'hui si l'essai en fait c'est la
ville oui assez simple
c'est que quelque chose de tordu ne me
ridiculiser pas devant tout le monde
peut-être moins car oui je sais ce que c
est vous cette saint valentin jeu
derrière soi bah j'ai écouté je me suis
couché à 20h15 oui voilà c'est très bien
parti julia
[Applaudissements]
une fleur tu es un fleuve
un flirt et une danse un fleuve on
embrasa non j'avais dit en embrasser en
draguant dans son onze ans relate une
danse en dansant ce soir à 21h sur
france 5 tout de suite on nouveau 2 ou
france 2 bien que je vois c'est pas
grave mais venez après sur france 2
après 3 bruno moyens saint valentin le
couple ça ne m'intéresse pas vraiment je
sois libre j'en ai rien à faire et je
vous souhaite une excellente journée et
le
certificateur
on peut vous appelez-vous ben écoutez
les ch'tis beaucoup et jamais vraiment
confiance aux hommes qu'il faut toujours
se méfier quand tu sais que beyoncé et
kylie jenner se sont fait tromper
i il faut toujours smith est et sebha
petit mais la bague au doigt où ça fait
5 costil il fera pas voir ailleurs au
contraire pour moi les somistes tous les
mêmes n'y a pas d'exception et moi perso
si vous me demandez une petite danse une
autre se retendent quand même
allons-y mais parce que je suis assez
d'accord si ça se trouve je veux dire en
général quand on veut dire un truc un
peu mais quand on se rencontre même
physiquement ce n'est pas toujours bien
du premier coup je vais jamais m'en
sortir avec cette frappe
[Musique]
bon
ça s'est il
passé va pouvoir en france pardon on n'a
rien à voir avec quelle aune en ski de
fond et les français vraiment des images
exceptionnelles regarde voilà je suis
alors il a seulement 11 ans bon la jeune
skieur américain seeberger alors les
images ont été captées par un parent ou
drones pour le filmer au plus près et
sur son instagram voilà on voit
enchaîner les rails l'eswc acrobatique
et l'impressionnent déjà les meilleurs
[Musique]
oui non oui enfin calmé pour toujours et
cet appel à témoins si vous me
connaissez cette personne a perçu en
duplex lors d'une course et la
seyne-sur-mer que vous avez compris le
but de sa démarche merci de nous
contacter au plus vite après deux ans et
demi de pandémie il faut qu'on lui parle
très vite car c'est aux talents
d'imitateur alors ben oui oui alors là
je suis censé imiter nelson donc bonjour
philippe
ça va mais pourquoi ils viennent pas
nous voir là parce qu'il ya le patinage
croyait le programme de l programme
court là ils y arrivent ils arrivent
mais voilà on se produit à bobino donc
bientôt la havane un
petit peu de travail quand même
je viens de faire une chute
impressionnante mais ça va
pardon donc je suis attendait voilà sans
chaussures pieds nus maintenant d'un don
excusez moi je suis désolé avoir un
homonyme qui fait de la politique ce
n'est pas forcément un cadeau eric
zemmour n'est pas candidat à l'élection
présidentielle mais un coiffeur qui
possède une dizaine de salons sur la
côte d'azur le nôtre c'est un coiffeur
c'est un artiste et ennour on préfère
rester lancement dans ce milieu là car
ça plairait que zemmour n'est pas bon
pour le business en ce moment en fin de
semaine dernière la devanture de cette
franchise du centre-ville a été
vandalisé et c'est loin d'être la
première dégradation que le salon subi
ce qui est très dérangeant aujourd'hui
c'est que voilà cassé des vitrines de
salon je trouve ça
les gens qui continuent à prendre des
photos bon ça peut faire rire et 2
minutes et ça commence à être fatiguant
le fait d'avoir des clients des gens qui
appellent et qui prennent rendez vous au
nom de manche en mêlant chant le pen ou
quoi je trouve ça horrible et la
présidentielle par les cieux vais vous
la suivez pourquoi vous les un repas fut
pas vu le bordel
non je suis pas je suis celle d'avant
voulait suiviez part dans celle d'avant
voulez vous les avez suivi depuis jose
était bourré chevet la menthe qu'importe
le flacon pourvu qu'on ait l'ivresse et
supportera flacon pourquoi pas une
canette en fret a basculé pour le vin en
canette pas nous non on est très en
vogue chez les anglo saxons les première
canette de 20 des bacs dans les rayons
et cible les jeunes consommateurs
analyse qu en août soit tu es toi ça
c'est impossible la sas et norouet b2
d'un go quoi
dit paraît que vous savez imiter le
bruit du vin versés dans le vert
alors moi je veux c'est faire déjà le
bouchon je vais le bouchon c'est ce qui
se passe après et après vous faites ce
qui se passe après attention
ah ouais pour regretter d'avoir fait ça
d'avoir son nom la sonnette de rien
parce que quand on est bourré ans et
plus et c'est formidable sa fuite donc
il faut faire attention il faut pas
lever les barrières immédiatement et
utiliser à fond le vaccin et inciter les
gens à aller se faire vacciner je sais
pas ça me semble d'une grande évidence
vous avez reçu pleins pleins de gens
bien plus compétent pour dire pour dire
toute sa compétence
il
ya pc-7 c'est cette mesure qui permet de
financer donc les pays qui veulent
adhérer à l'union européenne et c'est de
ça dont vous parlez c'est ce budget la
clé sur lg l'a amputé non mais celui tu
fasses doit béziers alors mais oui mais
pas n'importe quoi je les lui donne un
nom mais madame apic je dis pas vous
dites n'importe quoi je dis vous
mélanger deux propositions étaient
soignés dans la même ligue 2
transformations ilan qui a été effacé il
ya deux propositions ce programme a été
face à ce problème de la primaire il ya
deux il ya 2 2 pardon
gilbert bécaud si on était en cure de
désintoxication du nom
beaucoup de clients